hello everyone
my name is oliver i work for wolf from
research
in the numerix group and there i
work on the finite element method so if
you've
used ndsulf with the finite element
method or if you've used
nd eigensystem or interpolating
functions on
unstructured domains or to a lesser
degree
and integrate with the finite element
method you've
used functionality that i've worked on
in this talk we're going to show a
multiphysics
pde modding language that we're going to
introduce into version 12.2
and i'm going to start off with a brief
overview
so previously in version 12.0
we started to add pde modeling
capabilities in the sense that we've
added
pde models with a background theory
monograph and then accompanying those
monographs we had a model collection in
certain fields
for example acoustics or heat transfer
and in version 12.1 we've added
mass transport pde models
and if you want to look at those there's
some recordings of the previous years
where those have been presented let me
give you
a very quick glimpse on what those look
like in version 12.1
so you'd have this pde models
overview page um acoustics
electromagnetics heat transfer
um and the ones that are the what the
ones that are developed
have usually at least one monograph
um for example acoustics in the
frequency domain it explains a bit
the equation that's been used different
aspects of that
and certain boundary conditions that are
used
in those in this specific field um
and in this case we have a second one in
the time domain
um which has a similar structure um but
they
also have the acoustic models which are
kind of larger notebooks that have a
example or a larger example than what
you'd usually find in the documentation
and this acoustic mirror is presented
here
it has a pde and some code here to do
the pd modeling
in the end you set up the the domain
you do some meshing and some some other
specifications
for this model um you typically need to
set up initial and boundary conditions
you would solve the pde
with nd solve do some post processing um
visualizations and things like that so
all of that
is done um in these model
notebooks and in these monograph
tutorial tutorials
um however as as you've already seen
they've used some certain like small
code blocks to
to do the actual pde modeling so this is
the equation you'd wanted to model
but there was always some kind of a code
involved that needed to be copied to
every
um document that you wanted to use um
and the question is a bit
um could we do better than that
and so for version 12.2 we started
looking at
a pde modeling language so this is the
overview we've just seen from version
12.1
and we started by by thinking a bit
about what are design goals for such a
pde modeling language so the first thing
it needs to be documentable and by that
i mean
the pd's can become very complicated and
and in essence only a full derivation
of the specified pde actually tells you
what the pde does
and what the scope of the ptp is and
things like that
um so everything that we'd add we wanted
to have something like a ref
page and the ease of accessibility
comes to mind so you want to be able to
select some component or some some term
what not
press f1 and get to a reference page um
it needs to be easy to use so not
everyone is a pde expert so
even for non-pde experts this should be
usable
um it needs to be extendable by
customers um
just simply because we won't be able to
provide
every pde model that's available so
um it needs to go well with what people
do currently and
fit in nicely into that workflow um
another design goal was that we wanted
to um
people to see what this model generates
so
um you can understand what nd solve or
desolve
actually will be solving when you look
at these um these
models okay
so if we start looking at what are the
essentials that
need to go in any kind of a language
that we possibly come up so
we'd always need so if we're looking at
this this
um diffusion type of operator um we'd
always
need to specify the dependent variable u
in this case
we need to spend always specify
independent variables
um sometimes if it's time dependent we
need a time variable so that's not
present here or we might need a
frequency variable also not present here
and very often we need material
parameters like a diffusion coefficient
kappa
in this case so these are essential
components and some components that
might come up from time to time when you
do
modeling so
if you've seen the previous uh
presentation of mine
you'd know that the finite element
method basically solves this type of of
equation
and the first thing we did is we started
by um
generating the basic terms that this
equation represents so there's a
diffusion term this this this component
here
there is a convection term it's over
here
a reaction term source term and all of
these these
kind of terms pe terms now have a
reference page so
we uh gonna look and this this is now
version
12.2 the documentation so you see this
pde this diffusion pde term has been
added
um details section um like you know and
an example section uh is is is available
so there there you go um
but we're gonna we're gonna look at this
in a bit more detail um in a second
so and these are the basic terms that
are now
now present all right so
if you have such a a term for example
this
diffusion pde term you specify the
variables
u the dependent variable u of x and x
as a spatial variable as a list so this
is a slightly different um
than what you'd specified in ndsoft
where it's specified as a sequence but
that's uh we'll get to that in a second
um and then you specify the coefficient
as a second uh
argument so var's coefficient is is the
same pattern for all
pde uh terms that we have this is going
to return you
an inactive equation that's useful for
some cases when you have non-linear or
specific
neumann boundary conditions if you don't
like this inactive version you can
always
activate an active version and you'd get
what you've probably seen
from a calculus textbook so
that's also possible so here are a few
more uh
more possible inputs so the first thing
here is now so
you can now save the the variable setup
in a variable vars and use it throughout
all um terms that you that you're
computing so that's that's an advantage
which is harder to do with a sequence
so in this case we've added the
coefficient 23
here is a symbolic coefficient which is
a spatial variable so now it's space
dependent
here we add u the dependent variable as
a coefficient so it becomes a non-linear
coefficient
and in this case it's even a bit more
complicated where we have a spatial
dependency of the coefficient
if it's if it's um in a specific region
then use disk coefficient and if it's in
another region use that coefficient so
all
these sort of things are are uh possible
with this
um with these pde terms so how does this
look like in an equation so
we have this diffusion pde term uh
with the variable specification and the
coefficient specification we'll set this
equal to one and this gives an entire
equation
um so and you can call and desolve on
this equation
um just uh normally there's no
no new things needed here so
now this is the first more interesting
thing so now we can combine these terms
into sum so we have vars we specified
this here
we have diffusion pde term vars and the
coefficient one
minus one so you can interact in a in a
very normal
mathematical normal way with these
equations and terms
and to generate equations and this is
the same equation here
this time however we've used the
diffusion term and the source
pde term to model the same thing and
again you'd plug this in into and d
solve in exactly the same way like
you've used to do this
uh before adjust this is a different way
to generate this
note now that this virus is used twice
so i've only specified it once but
um in this entire um sum of pde terms we
we've used the same
vars specification which is convenient
the same is true for time dependent
terms um
so you've we've added a time dependent
uh dependent variable here plus the
diffusion term
uh equals to one and solve this in nd
solve in exactly the same way so this
this
operates nicely with all these um
different
components either you specified in a
classical way
partially in a classical way like this
time dependent
component and you've generate uh
the entire equation and this is the
major reason why these
pde terms and later the pde components
don't return equations themselves they
just return
um components or terms of equations and
you'll have to add them to you
to whatever you want yourself because
then they're
composable so to speak so you can add
them together
to form more complicated components so
so until now we've seen single terms and
combination of single terms
the next step then is to combine those
terms um
into larger components so
as we've seen already this is that the
equation we're kind of
solving this is the the coefficient form
of this equation
and if you switch on and off different
terms in this um coefficient form you
can model various equations um
so for example the poisson equation is
made up of a diffusion term
equals to a source term a helmholtz
equation again
is a diffusion term plus some reaction
term equal to a source term
heat equation time dependent term
diffusion term a source term so with
with switching on and off these
different terms you can model larger
types of equations so um what we
what we've then done is that we've added
named partial differential equation
components so for example we have this
helmholtz pde component and if we look
at this
in the documentation you now see so
vars and parse and i'll get to that in a
second is the input for all of them
again a details section on what it does
and how it works
and examples so
when we look at this so we have this
this virus is the dependent variable and
the independent variable
um the diffusion term
vars minus 1 plus the source pde term
vars minus 1 gives this specific
equation
but now we can also add this poisson
poisson pde component that has a
parameter
which is the source term and that gives
the exact same equation
note now the difference is because these
these pde terms always get one
coefficient um that however is not true
for the um for the pde components the
larger components they might have many
um coefficients to be specified so then
those coefficients are specified as an
association
in the parameters the important thing to
note however everything that has
pde component in its name will always
get
vars and parameters and everything that
has terms in its name will always get
vars
and a specific coefficient again
whatever is generated from either the
terms or the components can
be fed into and solve right
um right as i said pde components
variables and parameters is a typical
setup of these um and here's
a more specific example so we have an
acoustic pde component where you specify
p as a pressure time spatial variable x
t and x as a spatial variables with no
parameters given
will return a time dependent acoustic
model
if you don't specify any parameters some
default parameters will be
chosen um yeah so
um right the next thing to look at is
here is we have this
frequency domain acoustic model this is
the same acoustic pd
component um just by specifying p now
not as time dependent but as a frequency
dependent
component we'll get a different equation
so
um the acoustic pde component is capable
of
delivering different types of equations
for different
scenarios and that's true for all pde
components that we have
especially the physics fields related
ones
sometimes it's done by specifying a
different
parameter setup for the variables and
sometimes it's done via
the parameters of the pde component
so let's look at an example so i specify
a time i'd like to specify a time
dependent
uh acoustic pde model where i specify
the pressure
p t and x and i have a sound speed and a
density
and i evaluate this so the acoustic pd
component vars parse
equal to 0 gives me the specified
equation with the sound speed and
density that i've chosen
and i can then evaluate that and in a
normal way
and have a look at what what the
solution of this looks like you need to
specify initial conditions
um of course but that's um that's uh
that's not unusual of course
all right so the pd component is
one part um but we've also added new
boundary condition and boundary values
and those are there to interface the pde
that's active in the domain with the
rest of the world that's outside of the
domain
everything you're going to see is going
to evaluate so
what we have right now is dirichlet
condition and
neumann value and periodic condition and
everything you're going to see
now is going to either evaluate to a
daily condition
or annoyment value so basically what
we've done
is we've looked at certain fields of
physics and try to find the essential
boundary conditions there
um make a wrapper for them um that they
generate directly condition and neumann
values which is much easier
than to actually be then to actually
know how to set them up
yourself so we're going to have a look
at this now
so if something if some of these
boundary conditions
end in the in the word in the term
condition it's going to evaluate your
daily condition and if they evaluate
if then if they end in value they're
going to evaluate your annoyment value
and the argument pattern is the name of
the boundary condition
we specify the predicate where is it
active the vars and pars
and the virus and pars are exactly the
same for the corresponding
pde component so for example
an acoustic sound soft condition
specified at x
larger than zero for the following
variables no no
parameters specified evaluates to a
dirichlet condition so the
acoustic condition evals the directive
condition
the acoustic absorbing value um
evaluates to annoyment value
and note again in this case that
the time domain has been given and in
the second case the frequency domain has
been given
and the boundary condition knows how to
generate the proper neumann value
and that's true even if you specify uh
more parameters and things like that
okay so uh let's delete that for a
second
um we have the variable
again um the parameter is specified as
a sound speed and a density
um we evaluate this uh this model so we
have an acoustic pd component and an
acoustic sound heart value
this is essentially the same model we've
seen just now
it just now it doesn't use zero on the
right hand side but it uses
this acoustic sound heart value boundary
condition
and with this now you can start to do
nice things because now
you can go ahead and say for example i
don't want a sound heart value here i
want an acoustic absorbing value for
example here
and the model is adjusted accordingly so
and now if you evaluate this
you'll get a different behavior on the
right hand side
boundary condition because you have
different um a different
boundary condition there so we've
basically we've decoupled
the equation from its components
and this means that you can also go
ahead and say for example
parse um should
for example go to
material and the material goes to
tungsten
tungsten um so this this
this thing also works and this now
generates you
the material um the
acoustic pde that you wanted for the
material tungsten so
you don't have to go around and fiddle
with the equation you just
specify or change the parameters in the
parameters section and then everything
will fall into place automatically so
this is a major a major uh
benefit of this new technology
one other thing to keep in mind is um
that we can specify local versus global
boundary condition parameters so
say for example an acoustic radiation
value
has additional parameters like a sound
incidence pressure or sound direction
vector
these can be specified in the parameter
section so i've joined the parameters
density and sound speed but you can also
separate them so you can say the third
argument is the parameters density and
sound speed
and the force argument are these
specific
to this boundary condition the specific
um
specifications um this has um
and it gives the same results so but
this has a great advantage because if
you want to specify the same boundary
condition
at different places with different local
um components you can that can then um
do so
so where x equals uh is larger than one
then we've got bars and parameters and
then
bc one is basically this the the local
specification for this
acoustic radiation value and the bc2
contains the local specification for
this um
second boundary condition so then you
you can combine multiple
of the same boundary condition
in and still use the parameter um setup
method okay so
um let me quickly um have a quick a
a look at the different pde modeling
fields of physics that we have um
and there i think that the important
thing is to look at
um so so we've discussed these basic
building blocks um that are now
available um we've got discussed the
named partial functional equations a bit
we've looked a bit at these acoustics
pde
uh components uh we we also have
a heat transfer pde component and a mass
transport pd component
so these are the components that
generate the equations
and these are the boundary conditions
that we have and there's always a
at least one monograph expanding in much
more detail
of what this um equation does uh and how
it's derived and things like that
um what we also have is and if you if
you if you go and do some
look at this one maybe heat transfer
that's a specific
um heat transfer boundary con and
boundary condition
guide page that we have this explains in
a bit more detail
what these boundary conditions do and
all of them of course have have um
reference pages
you can can look at them and we've gone
through great lengths um
as in explaining what they do so
um yeah and what what this page also has
this sub guide page also has
is the specific models um that we've
done for the heat transfer so for
example if we look at
the shrink fitting example here
you can look at those examples
right so um and additionally there is a
small
list of what functionality is
um is discussed in each of these
extended um
examples so if you're looking for a 3d
example
you might look at the dual heating or
the laser welding
application example so that gives you a
bit more more information of where to
find
what if you're looking for something uh
specific
okay um right
so what i wanted to try to do in the
remaining a few minutes
is to discuss a an advanced research
type of application that can be done
with this so we're going to look at
catalyst deactivation
and catalyst deactivation um so you use
a catalyst to increase a chemical
reaction
the catalyst per se is not consumed
by the reaction but it's deactivated in
in the example that i'm going to show
it's going to be deactivated by coca
accumulation um so
this is a gas solid catalyst reaction so
we have a reactant g
um a catalyst side s and there is a
reaction
um constant k1 that produces p
the product that we're interested in and
the
catalyst remains unchanged but the
catalyst
with time um uh reacts with the product
uh and accumulates um coke and it's
going to be deactivated by that
so um what we have here is a microscopy
image of a catalyst particle
and what you see here is the catalyst
site
this is this is the actual catalyst and
the reactant is flowing uh through this
um
catalyst site and um doing is
its thing to form the product um but at
the same time
is going to deactivate the catalyst
and this is done with a mass transport
equation which i've written here
so we have three species we have the um
uh the the the um the reactant
the source and the product and we have
diffusivity for all of those
and there's a rate of mass production
consumption
for all of those so these are the
reaction rates
that are given for the specific
concentrations
and those are plugged into the equation
basically like this and now to do to do
this modeling the only thing is um
what you need to do so now we've
specified three dependent variables
that's something i didn't speak about
before but those
mass transport or the pde components are
vectorizable so you can specify multiple
dependent variables
we specify time and the spatial
coordinates
and then we just specify the parameter
mass diffusivity
the mass source and this sets up the
entire equation that we've written here
um and then you basically your modeling
com
component is is basically done what
remains to be done is now
to to specify the domain so we we have
this microscopy image
which we uh binarize so we will get a
black and white
black and white image of that um and
from this
uh we'll form a mesh so we we take this
binarized image
image mesh will form a mesh we resize
the mesh to a realistic scale and then
with some
image processing we find all the
catalyst sites
all the red dots are catalyst sites and
we use those to form an element mesh
so here we've generate a mesh which has
a 300 000 plus some
triangle elements and in blue you see
all catalyst
sites um so
the parameters are specified we start
with an
empty association the diffusivity
is specified in the solid and gas
mass diffusivity is specified as the
parameter
we move on to specified boundary
conditions so
in this case we have a mass transfer
value
again the position where it's active
bars parameters
a mass transfer coefficient you specify
the one you want we specify boundary
conditions
so this is a mass concentration
condition
we say that for this specific component
we have a mass concentration and that's
a function that
generates that that concentration
condition
initial conditions as specified for all
time dependent problems
[Music]
then we set up the pde the mass
transport pd component
vars parse the flux and the
concentration condition initial
condition
um this then is 2 million degrees of
freedom so it's a large scale problem
we stuck this we put this into ndsulf
it will compute the reactant uh
functions of those takes uh
1100 seconds to compute a little more
than
um 11 gigabytes of memory required
and then we'll have the um the catalyst
down here how it changes over time the
concentration in mole per cubic meter
the product and the reactant and from
that we can still compute
the coke accumulation by doing this
equation again
so we multiply these two components so
with the reactant equation
and time integrate over it and then
you'll see how much coke has been
accumulated
in this microscopy generated image
in five seconds um
yes so i think my time is almost up so
i thank you very much for your attention
the modeling guide and the models
overview are probably the most
two essential components for um
starting your modeling
career if you will with the wolfram
language
that will give you an overview or
starting points for doing
so one last thing i'd like to mention is
that
later today there is a finite element
meetup so if you are into finite
elements and things like that
um you're most welcome to join me uh
later today
um that's it from my site um
for my part sorry um i'll um
probably i'll discuss questions that you
probably will have for this
in the in the meetup for the finite
elements um
i think we'll have a bit more time to do
this uh over there then yeah
so hope to see you later and enjoy the
conference
bye for now
you